facebook rebranding to meta is like an
interesting kind of moment because it
actually speaks to offense and defense
facebook's defense is
there's been a lot of pressure on the
brand it's an aging up brand it's
skewing older and that means a little
tired of a brand and means an old thing
number two there's been a lot of
pressure on privacy and congress and all
this stuff so
the defense side is obvious i think the
offense side is even more interesting to
me facebook's greatest strength over the
last two decades has been going to where
the attention is they bought instagram
they tried to buy snapchat and most
importantly they've been crushing in my
opinion building the foundation for
oculus and being in the metaverse i see
facebook being a serious nft player a
serious metaverse player the timing was
exactly right and for all us
entrepreneurs here and operators timing
is everything
offense is always a better reason to
rebrand but when it also coincides with
defense it becomes an obvious move